i've never been able to manifest a
mutual friendship
never even had a cup of coffee in a cafe
without my anxiety kicking in
never even celebrated my birthday i am
meant to be lonely
[Music]
when i was between 12 and 15 i used to
hug the clothes in my closet just to
feel like i'm hugging someone real
i grew up to realize that i never
actually liked the human connection
i don't like to be touched or held it's
been years
since i hugged someone
i feel that because of my parents
divorce
that my family members treat me
differently than my cousins
whose parents are together whenever we
have family gatherings
i'm always the one who is forgotten
about and sits alone
separated from everyone i feel as though
i would never be truly loved
or treated as a member of the family
because there's no difference in whether
i'm there or not
oh wow in high school i used to eat
lunch in the bathroom stall
i do the same in my workplace now
i grew up a military brat
so i ended up moving every year of high
school and
the hardest thing was in the first week
of going to a new school and
finding myself alone in the lunchroom
so i definitely understand where this
person is coming from
i would say it's better to be proactive
and not wait around for somebody to
approach you
i think you have to make the first move
as a child i never talked to my toys
but now i'm 24 and ever since i've been
living alone i talk to my stuffed
animals when i feel my friends don't
want to talk to me anymore
i'm a little embarrassed to say this but
i talk to myself
all the time every day all day long
because i also live alone until you have
really been in the depths of loneliness
it is so hard to describe
like the lengths that you go and the
things that you do to try to combat
it and i think if talking to your toys
brings you some comfort like we need
that because loneliness is something
that you can drown in
it is something that can overcome you i
think people can be alone but not lonely
you know there are people who are
happily single there are people who
choose to never get married there are
people who choose to never have a
partner
and they're perfectly happy with that
and i think loneliness
is when you long to have those things
and you don't
and you feel like you have no control
over it all right that's been my
experience at least
my best friend unfriended and abandoned
me without a word after i told her i was
suicidal
i still blame myself to this day i wish
i was different
and maybe we would still be friends
oh that's tough because
if they are your best friend then i feel
like they wouldn't unfriend you
or abandon you especially when you're in
such a vulnerable place
i think to a certain extent as a friend
as a human being you have to be there
for the people around you
and vice versa i think we can do things
alone we need people around us
i feel so lonely that i get chest pains
and i can't breathe
people think i'm fine because i have a
good job i'm well educated and rich
but they don't know that i cry myself to
sleep almost every night because i long
to be with someone
all i want is for someone to hold me to
brush their fingertips across my cheek
gently rub my back and grab my hand i
feel so helpless because i don't know
when i'll find somebody to love and if
i'll ever have someone to love me back
i think what's really interesting about
that person's response is
how much they kind of gravitated towards
the physical
when you get to
hold someone you love and you care about
and you get that
momentary euphoria like when you hug
someone that you haven't seen for a long
time and you're almost like
brain dead for a few seconds when you're
when you're holding that person i think
that's something that a lot of people
look forward to and
and crave in their in their lives i
appear very happy and outgoing from the
outside
but i constantly have panic attacks that
no one knows about i'm scared i'm going
to hurt myself
my parents are immigrants who don't
believe in mental health issues
one night at dinner my mom told me stop
saying you have anxiety you don't even
look sick
i'm going to take you to the hospital to
see dying kids so you can see what real
sickness is like
sometimes i wonder that maybe there is
nothing like mental health issues
maybe they're just constraints of the
mind
that must be such an isolating feeling
i have immigrant parents as well and
mental health was not something we ever
spoke about growing up
and so it was hard to say things that
i'm like i think i need to go see a
therapist or like i think i need help
trying to figure out my emotions when
i'm seeing you as like happy and
outgoing like this person is
but then you tell me you have these
problems you know i can understand how
it would be hard
for someone to understand that but we
shouldn't
we should take people at their word if
you are feeling a certain way should
always believe them
once i had a breakdown and i had no one
to talk to
so i went to the cinema on my own and
ended up sharing a good vibe with a
solo watcher next to me even though we
didn't exchange any words
i felt better afterwards sometimes you
don't need
someone you know to make you feel a
little less lonely
the environment of movie theaters it's
so
communitive you know you're all sharing
an experience you're all sharing a story
you're all sharing
at some points and emotion the times
where i was very lonely
you know when i was when i was younger i
think movies and being in movie theaters
helped me because
i had that shared experience to rely
upon
i am a closeted gay adopted from korea
with crippling depression since i was
12.
i've never felt 100 korean or 100
part of my white family's culture i feel
like the christian god could not love a
deformed creation
i have no one to turn to not my church
not my family not my friends not my
culture
i'm totally and utterly alone i'm a
misfit everywhere
dang
all i could say is like you're not a
misfit
i wish this wasn't a secret i mean i'm
so glad they shared it
like on paper
but i know so many people that are like
this what's really tough is that they
say i have no one to turn to
i think they've got to find that one
person
whether professional or personal they
need to find
one person to allow them to feel like
they can turn to them and talk to them
but i'm also christian and you know
there's a part of me that really hates
christianity
because i feel like the christian god
could not love a deformed creation
when i was 14 15 years old
one of my best friends is buddhist
and i told some people at a church
like retreat or group that i went to
and they were like oh you got to save
your friend you're not a good christian
because you won't save them
and i was like what is wrong we tend to
politicize
certain things
but god loves all so
at least that's what i believe
[Music]